cuando empezamos a estudiar la
electricidad necesitamos tener una buena
idea de qué es la corriente y el voltaje
y eso lo vimos en dos vídeos anteriores
corriente
y voltaje y cuando hablamos acerca de la
corriente es más fácil si tenemos un
cable de cobre así es que vamos a poner
por aquí un cable de cobre y sabemos que
adentro tenemos electrones sueltos y
también sabemos que los electrones
tienen una carga negativa así es que si
les ponemos un voltaje estos electrones
se moverían en alguna dirección si le
ponemos un voltaje a este cable un
voltaje positivo por acá y uno negativo
por acá los electrones sienten repulsión
hacia esta carga negativa y sienten
atracción hacia esta carga positiva los
electrones sienten repulsión por el
voltaje negativo y sienten atracción por
el voltaje positivo y entonces se mueven
hacia el voltaje positivo y a eso le
llamamos corriente de electrones
corriente de electrones bueno también lo
podríamos llamar flujo de electrones
pero en este vídeo le vamos a llamar
corriente de electrones y hablar de la
corriente en términos de lo que está
sucediendo en el cable de cobre tiene
mucho sentido y es mucho más fácil de
entender es muy sencillo pensar en estos
electrones con carga negativa moviéndose
en alguna dirección y cuando hablemos
específicamente acerca de esto diremos
que tenemos una corriente de electrones
o un flujo de electrones y como los
electrones se mueven hacia el voltaje
positivo la corriente de electrones
tiene esta dirección sin embargo como
mencionamos en un vídeo anterior
tenemos una convención para la dirección
de la corriente la corriente eléctrica
convencional fluye en la dirección
contraria corriente convencional
la convención que hemos tenido por
cientos de años es que la corriente se
mueve en la dirección en la que una
carga positiva se movería en caso de
existir así es que de ahora en adelante
siempre que hablemos de una corriente
nos estamos refiriendo a la corriente
convencional de hecho ni siquiera
tenemos que mencionar que nos referimos
a la corriente convencional
siempre decimos corriente y tiene la
dirección en la que se moverían las
cargas positivas si alguna vez nos
referimos a la corriente de electrones
entonces diremos corriente de electrones
ahora por otro lado también vimos el
concepto de voltaje e hicimos una
analogía con la gravedad y una montaña
y en esta montaña tenemos una pila una
batería y lo que dijimos es que esta
batería bombea electrones a la cima de
la montaña y luego bueno pues esos
electrones bajan la montaña y se
reincorporan al lado positivo de la
batería y cuando diseñamos circuitos lo
que hacemos es colocar por aquí algunos
componentes en el camino de bajada del
electrón y aquí es donde diseñamos
nuestro circuito ahora por aquí el flujo
de electrones la corriente de electrones
está fluyendo en esta dirección
entonces la corriente convencional está
fluyendo en la dirección contraria está
fluyendo hacia acá
ok está es la corriente que siempre
vemos en los circuitos y la corriente de
electrones está fluyendo hacia acá así
es que pues vamos a voltear el circuito
voy a poner la batería
y ponemos el circuito por acá de esta
forma
y este es el circuito que teníamos por
acá este es el lado positivo de la
batería este es el lado negativo el lado
positivo es el que tiene la barra larga
y el lado negativo tiene la barra corta
y en los circuitos la dirección de la
corriente convencional a la que
simplemente le llamamos corriente la
dirección de la corriente es en este
sentido ok
esta es y la corriente sale del lado
positivo pasa por todo el circuito y
llega al lado negativo y de ahora en
adelante es a esto a lo que nos
referimos con corriente a la corriente
convencional aunque sabemos que los
electrones en este circuito los
electrones en estos cables están
fluyendo en esta otra dirección pero
esta es nuestra nomenclatura de la
corriente convencional o simplemente
corriente